[Music]
i've been through
18 foster homes
five group homes
and five shelters five different
shelters in the past 13 years my parents
had recently had got a divorce
i would have like bad thoughts and would
end up
actually hearing cincinnati children's a
lot so that's when they decided that it
would be better for me to go to the
foster care system so
there are about 470 000 children in
foster care across the united states
and of kids in foster care they have
disjointed medical care
and when they change placements or
change to a new foster family they
frequently change and potentially lose
their medical records when your
caseworkers drop you off they don't give
them the information that they need they
just let them know hey got this child
she's a female she's this age and we'll
be bringing her in do you have any beds
open so i applied for an nlm grant
because what the nlm is trying to do
with health disparities and health
disparities research fits directly into
what we want to do with our care
our goal was to start with the kids who
are 18 and over who are eligible for or
emancipating out of care and help
provide them with both their medical
records and a portion of their data from
job and family services so from the
people who have their actual custody so
they could see their records they could
see their major diagnoses their current
medications their immunizations
and then they could become stewards of
their own data but then they also headed
in a form that they could take with them
as they transitioned from pediatric to
adult care one of the reasons i used
hefner was to set up my appointment for
my pregnancy
i did not remember all my testing that i
had done because i never had like actual
copy of my insurance card so my
insurance card was on there and they can
scan it and put it through their system
if you don't know your information by
heart it will be there for you to
remember
and it just like it helps it shows you
more information that you can learn
outside of what people tell you
one of the great things about doing the
funding through the national library of
medicine is the primary focus was how to
build
an application with the end users
involved in a novel way
how to get it out to them so that they
could put it in their hands again
and then how to evaluate whether or not
they used it a feature on health hero
that was helpful to me
was under immunization records i was
able to log in look at my records and
print it out to
get into nursing school
i grew up
in the hospital and that made me want to
become a nurse because i would become
very close to the nurse
i would just like to take care of people
for the rest of my life if i ever get
the chance
it's important for youth that's being
emancipated to have healthy role because
of the fact that
it's just something that you need to
know
it's you're not going to always have
someone there that remembers all your
information
my advice to a person that was going
through what i went through is
you never give up you don't let the
foster care make you who you are
you always fight
and you don't give up you don't let the
foster care define you you don't let it
break you
[Music]